San Bernardino California is grieving
again barely a year up a deadly terror
attack hundreds of children walked
hand-in-hand yesterday as they were
evacuated from their school police want
to know my man walked into a
special-needs classroom and shot a
teacher dead he also killed one student
before turning a gun on himself
police say the teacher was the gunman's
estranged wife and the students were not
targets but hundreds of upset parents
who rushed the school had to wait for
hours to see their children John
Blackstone is outside North Park
Elementary School in San Bernardino
which is closed after the shooting John
what a tough morning there it is indeed
and good morning while another student
was also shot that student is in stable
condition in the hospital this morning
the couple was married less than three
months ago investigators are trying to
figure out what happened between then
and yesterday's violence the shots were
fired before 10:30 Monday morning
authorities scrambled to secure the area
as they quickly evacuated some 500
students and discovered two of them had
been shot police say 53 year-old cedric
anderson entered his wife's classroom it
is my understanding that he entered the
office and he had simply said that he
was there to drop something off with his
wife according to authorities his
estranged wife Karen Smith was his
target he aimed a 357 revolver at the 53
year old and she was killed also shot
were two students standing behind her
worried parents waited for hours to be
reunited with their children who were
transported to a nearby campus
eight-year-old jonathan martinez was
airlifted to hospital where he died an
unidentified nine-year-old boy is
hospitalized in stable condition the
class had 15 students from 1st through
4th grade this 7 year old girl is one of
them I cross the room what did you do
teaching assistant Jocelyn Kelly was
there in the class police say Anderson
then killed himself I'm told he does
have a criminal history it has to do
with weapons charges
domestic violence past as well as
possible drug charges in there as well I
mean babies any movie the two were
married in late January but police say
they were recently estranged Anderson
praised his wife on Facebook less than
two months ago she is making really we
do know that they were estranged we do
not know the reason if they were
estranged yet that'll be part of the
investigation
Smith's pastor says she was a
compassionate and talented teacher who
had a heart for children the school
district says counselors will be
available today for families students
and staff Alix a terrifying day for
parents over there thanks John